i i preached a message a couple weeks
ago about this guy that went up in these
weather balloons
in a lawn chair because he said i just
couldn't sit there
and and and i just think that if more
people just say i just couldn't sit
there i got to do something right and i
just saw this is something to to be in
solidarity with you with with what's
happening down here
[Music]
hey we're still here that's right my
name is pastor corey brooks and i'm on
top of this rooftop for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bring
awareness to the violence in chicago but
most of all trying to raise enough funds
to build a community center on this
block that is much needed called o block
it's called o named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up his name and started
calling it o block we decided to keep
the o but we want to call it opportunity
block and every day fox gives me the
opportunity to bring you rooftop
revelations and i am so
thankful today i have with us a guest
his name is paul gleiman he's a pastor
and we're going to jump right in we want
to talk just a little bit about what's
going on in chicago and he's in the
suburbs and we're here in chicago but he
he knows enough and one of the things
that we've been discussing is
we really feel like
one of the things that we're missing out
on
is unity
and so paul when we talk about unity uh
and we talk about
getting rid of the violence and the
poverty in chicago
how do you see
that becoming a part of the whole
scenario well i think for us as the
church the bible tells us we're the body
of christ doesn't say we have to try to
be doesn't say that we should be it says
that we are yes and the christ is the
head and
when you know i appreciate what you're
doing down here and that that's why i
came down i want to be a part of it but
i needed someone to kind of show me how
we can do something in a positive way
but i i was just saying to you that what
if what if you got a text from someone
and they said what what did you send me
this message for what is that why did
you say this you say i didn't send that
message but your thumb just did its own
thing
but sometimes that's where we are in the
body of christ we're not we're not
working together but so it's a challenge
i'm giving our church that this year the
beginning of the year just say man i'm
gonna i'm gonna listen to the head i'm
gonna listen to jesus and i'm i'm gonna
go with the rest of the body and then i
think that we can accomplish so much
more together than we can just by
ourselves yeah you know i believe you're
right i think one of the things that we
see in america is a great divide and one
of the reasons why we're not
accomplishing as much as we probably
could accomplish is because we are such
a divided nation and people are so
divided we're black and white and
christians and non-christians and
republicans and democrats but there
comes a time when there have to be some
causes where we have to be unified and
that's reason why
i think violence is something that we
could all
come to the rescue for and and so i
appreciate your being here but i want to
ask you this
why would
you come all the way from the suburbs
to the south side of chicago on top of
this rooftop
well
it's chicago is my home i mean i live in
the suburbs but and i've said this to
people i i've been to basically every
major city in the united states except
boston chicago is such a beautiful city
but it does have
a reputation for violence which one is
it is it the beautiful city or the
violent city it's both but i want to do
something i i preached a message a
couple weeks ago about this guy that
went up in these weather balloons
in a lawn chair because he said i just
couldn't sit there
and and and i just think that if more
people just say i just couldn't sit
there i got to do something right and i
just saw this is something to to be in
solidarity with you with with what's
happening down here and i'm excited
about what's what's happening here i
want to i want to be a part of it
absolutely you know i'm grateful for
your presence and thankful because i
think if we as pastors
can can work together more often and
somehow figure out ways to get our
churches to work together more often
there's so much
that we can accomplish to help the world
and
going forward
what do you see
yourself doing more of do you do you
think taking more action steps toward
things like this
in your future and and what do you tell
people to encourage them to do the same
well absolutely and and uh we chatted a
little bit earlier that i've done a lot
of short term mission trips and a lot of
them
to chicago but uh you know a lot of
times as the pastor i can kind of get my
foot in the door and so i know that you
know our people on sunday are really
going to be excited to hear about what
happened and uh i know i'm going to have
some stories to tell them yeah and
challenge them
you can do similar kinds of things and
and we can find ways that we can partner
where we can partner as west hills
community church with with project hood
yeah you know i want to thank paul and i
want to thank all of you who
have consistently
been supporting our efforts and showing
unity from all across america from every
state and every city that you can
imagine uh people have been coming to
our aid and to our assistance because
that's what it's really going to take in
order for us to build this center in
order for us to change and save more
lives it's going to take all of us
working together so i want to thank fox
for giving us this platform every day
rooftop revelations and i want to thank
all of the american people for just
being so awesome and so wonderful it's
great uh to be an american and live in
the us of a so god bless america god
bless you paul and your church and thank
you for being here today and uh
hopefully we'll do some more work amen
amen as i always say i'll see you
tomorrow
peace
you